you
the senate will come to order the
chaplain
dr black will open the senate with
prayer
let us pray god
of our forebears author
of liberty we lift our hearts
in praise thank you
for the opportunity to witness
a renewal of democracy
and an orderly transition
of power lord
we know this orderly transition
was not inevitable for
your grace saved us
mighty god let the healing
begin bless our
incoming senators
give wisdom and courage to president
joseph r biden and vice president
kamala harris for the living
of these days and lord
long may our land be bright
with freedom's holy light
protect us by your might
great god our king
we pray in your sovereign name
amen
will you all please join me in the
pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible
with liberty and justice for all
the democratic leader i suggest the
absence of the bomb
clerk we'll call the roll miss baldwin
[Music]
[Applause]
so
the chair lays before the senate two
certificates of election for the state
of georgia
and a certificate of appointment to fill
the vacancy
created by the resignation of former
senator kamala d harris of california
[Applause]
yeah that was very weird okay
the certificates the chair is advised
are in the form suggested by the senate
if there be no objection the reading of
the certificates will be waived
and they will be printed in full in the
record
if the senator's elect and senator
designate
will now present themselves at the desk
the chair will administer
the oath of office
mr ossoff mr padilla
mr warnock
please raise your right hand okay
do you solemnly swear that you will
support and defend
the constitution of the united states
against all enemies
foreign and domestic that you will bear
true faith
and allegiance to the same that you take
this obligation freely
without any mental reservation or
purpose of evasion
and that you will well and faithfully
discharge the duties
of the office on which you are about to
enter
so help you god
[Applause]
congratulations
[Applause]
uh
president and madam vice president
majority leader just to let the members
know the order of business we will first
uh
install senator leahy as president pro
tem we will then have some
uh other sort of just mechanical
business i will then give my maiden
speech
as majority leader of the united states
senate
and then we'll he
and then we'll hear from senator
mcconnell there may be a vote
this evening
unanimous consent the senate proceed to
the consideration of senate resolution
six
submitted earlier today the clerk will
report the resolution
senate resolution six to elect patrick j
leahy a senator from the state of
vermont to be president pro
tempore of the senate of the united
states
is there objection to the proceeding or
the measure without objection the senate
will proceed to the measure
madam president i ask unanimous consent
the resolution be agreed to and that the
motion to reconsider be considered made
and laid upon the table with no
intervening action or debate
is there an objection without objection
so ordered
the senior senator from vermont will be
escorted to the desk
please raise your right hand do you
solemnly swear that you will support
and defend the constitution of the
united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic i do that you will
bear true faith and allegiance to the
same
and that you take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation
or purpose of evasion and that you will
well and faithfully discharge
the duties of the office upon which you
are about to enter
so help you god i do congratulations
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so
i ask unanimous consent the senate
proceed to the consideration of s
resolution
seven submitted earlier today without
objection
and the clerk will report the resolution
senate resolution seven expressing the
thanks of the senate to the honorable
chuck grassley for his service as
president pro
tempore of the united states senate and
to designate
senator grassley as president pro
tempore
emeritus of the united states senate
the clerk will report the res uh is
their objection to proceed to the
measure
and without objection the senate will
proceed to the measure
i ask unanimous consent the resolution
be agreed to
and that the motion to reconsider be
made and laid upon the table with no
intervening action or debate
not that is objection there's none
without objection so ordered
mr president the majority leader
i ask unanimous consent the senate
proceed to the consideration of senate
resolution eight submitted earlier today
clerk will report the resolution senate
resolution aid
notifying the president of the united
states of the election of a president
pro
tempore is there objection to proceeding
to the measure
without objection hearing none the
senate will proceed to the measure
mr president i ask unanimous consent the
resolution be agreed to in the
and that the motion to reconsider be
made and laid upon the table with no
intervening action or debate
is there objection without objection so
ordered
mr president i ask unanimous consent
the senate proceed to the consideration
of senate resolution nine submitted
earlier today
clerk report the resolution senate
resolution nine
notifying the house of representatives
of the election of a president pro
tempore as your objection proceed the
measure
without objection the senate will
proceed to the measure
i ask unanimous consent that the
resolution be agreed to the motion be
recons to to reconsider be considered
made
and laid upon the table with no
intervening action or debate
is there objection without objection so
order
mr president i ask unanimous consent the
senate proceed to the consideration of
senate resolution 10 submitted earlier
today
quickly report the resolution senate
resolution 10
electing gary b myrick of virginia as
secretary
for the majority of the senate the
objection to proceeding to the measure
hearing none senate will proceed to the
measure
i ask unanimous consent that the
resolution be agreed to and that the
motion to be
reconsidered be considered made and laid
upon the table with no intervening
action or debate
sir objection not hearing objection it's
ordered
mr president i ask unanimous consent
the senate proceed to the consideration
of senate resolution 11 submitted
earlier today
the clerk will report the resolution
senate resolution 11
electing robert m duncan of the district
of columbia as secretary
for the minority of the senate is there
objection to proceeding to the measure
hearing none the senate will proceed to
the
measure i ask unanimous consent the
resolution be agreed to
and the motion to be re to reconsider be
considered made and laid upon the table
with no intervening action or debate
is your objection hearing none without
objection sorted
mr president the majority leader
mr president i need to catch my breath
so much is happening
a few hours ago on the west front of
this citadel of democracy
joe biden and kamala harris were
administered the oaths of office to the
presidency and the vice presidency of
the united states
we have turned the page to a new chapter
in the history of
our democracy and i am full of hope
i would challenge anyone not to feel
hopeful today
after listening to amanda gordon the
amazing 22 year old poet
wise far behind beyond her years
who told us that quote somehow we've
we've weathered and witnessed
a nation that isn't broken but simply
unfinished the hope she spoke about
strong and happy hope the hope we feel
today
is a hope of course that's tempered by
reality
this was an inauguration unlike most
others
the crowds that customarily line the
national mall were absent a reminder
that our nation is still in the throes
of a deadly pandemic the presence of
thousands of national guardsmen police
and secret service
was a reminder that two weeks ago in
this very room
and on on those very steps where
president biden took the oath
a mob of violent criminals tried to
dismantle our democracy
our sacred democracy brick by brick
and would try again if they could but
as president biden said a few hours ago
today democracy has prevailed the will
of the people was heated the peaceful
transfer of power fulfilled
it takes a lot more than a band of
hooligans
to bring our grand democracy down
let it be a message to our friends and
adversaries around the world that our
democracy
though it has been tried and been tested
shall long
endure and let it be a message to those
terrorists who desecrated this temple of
democracy that they will never
prevail joe biden
is now the 46th president of the united
states
kamala harris is now the 49th vice
president
of the united states but of course in
more ways than one she is not the 49th
but the first
the first african-american woman the
first asian-american woman the first
woman period
to hold the office of vice presidency in
our nation's history
today the threat to our democracy from
the presidency itself
has ended but the challenges we face as
a nation
remain in the wake of violence and
division hatred and mistruth
in the shadow of disease and economic
hardship
a warming planet an unequal society
we begin the work of the 117th congress
in his inaugural address president biden
spoke to this moment
a moment of great challenge and told us
two
simple truths one that our
responsibilities
are numerous and two it will take unity
unity of spirit unity of purpose to
fulfill them
president biden we heard you loud
and clear we have a lengthy agenda
and we need to get it done together
president biden pointed the way to our
nation's recovery and renewal
he reminded us of who we are and where
we need to go
but we must now turn the spirit of his
words
into action the senate must immediately
set to work on the mission president
biden described restoring the greatness
and goodness of america this will be an
exceptionally busy and consequential
period for the united states senate
there is much to do and we
are ready to get to work
now not to upstage our new president and
vice president
but theirs has not been the only
swearing-in today
a few moments ago the senate welcomed
three new members to this chamber
i can now happily and proudly call them
senator
padilla senator
ossoff senator warnock
they joined senators kelly hickenlooper
and lujan
as part of a six-member class of
democratic senators
and a new democratic senate majority
i mentioned the historic nature of vice
president harris's ascendance but let's
not forget that her successor
alex padilla is the first latino senator
to represent california that raphael
warnock
born while georgia was represented in
this chamber
by two staunch segregationists
is now the first african-american
senator
georgia has ever elected
and that john ossoff is the first jewish
senator from his state
sworn in today on a book of hebrew
scripture
once owned by the rabbi who decades ago
formed a bond between the jewish and
african-american communities of georgia
as president biden said in his inaugural
address
don't tell me things can't change
with the swearing-in of these three
senators the senate will turn to
democratic
control for which i deeply thank
my colleagues we'll turn to democratic
control under the first
new york-born majority leader in
american history
a kid from brooklyn the son of an
exterminator
and a housewife the descendant of
victims
of the holocaust that i should be the
leader
of this new senate majority is an
awesome
responsibility awesome in the biblical
sense
as the angels that trembled before
that trembled in awe before god
today i feel the full weight of that
responsibility a sense of reverence
of awe at the trust placed in me
i intend to honor that trust with all of
my energy
and with joy
and as the majority changes in the
senate
the senate will do business differently
the senate will address the challenges
our country faces head on and without
delay
not with timid solutions but with
boldness and with courage
the senate will tackle the perils of the
moment a once-in-a-generation health and
economic crisis
and it will strive to make progress on
generations-long struggle
for racial justice economic justice
equality of opportunity
and equality under the law and make no
mistake
the senate will forcefully consistently
and urgently address the greatest threat
to this country and to our planet
climate change this senate will
legislate
it will be active responsive
energetic and bold and to my republican
colleagues
when and where we can the democratic
majority will strive to make
this important work bipartisan
the senate works best when we work
together we have no choice
the challenges we face are great the
divisions in the country are real
we have no choice but to try to work
together
every day to reward the faith the
american people
have placed in us so let us begin
i yield the floor
the republican leader
mr president today
before the american people in the world
the peaceful transfer of power that has
helped define our nation
for more than 230 years
was carried out we swore in the 46th
president and the 49th vice president
of the united states president biden and
vice president harris are both
alumni of the u.s senate they're well
known to us
in this chamber they begin their terms
with both
challenges and opportunities before them
and with the prayers of our whole nation
at their backs president biden made
unity the major theme of his inaugural
address
he pledged to be a president for all
americans
to work as hard for the many millions of
americans
who did not support his candidacy as he
will for the millions
who did so i congratulate my friend from
delaware
look forward to working with him as our
new president
wherever possible our country deserves
for both sides both parties to find
common ground for the common good
everywhere that we can
and disagree respectfully where we must
last fall the american people chose to
elect a narrowly divided house of
representatives
a 50-50 senate
and a president who promised unity
the people intentionally entrusted both
political parties with significant power
to shape our nation's direction
may we work together to honor that trust
earlier today i was honored to present
our former colleague vice president
harris with a flag that flew over her
historic swear again
as our nation's first woman vice
president
this groundbreaking achievement elicits
national pride
that transcends politics
all citizens can applaud the fact that
this
new three-word phrase
madam vice president is now
part of our american lexicon
so once again our sincere
congratulations to our former colleague
from california on this day
i also joined my colleagues in warmly
welcoming welcoming our three
newest senators senator padilla of
california
senator zasoff and warnock of georgia
have been sent to this chamber by their
home states to represent their neighbors
and to serve our nation we have plenty
of senate business to discuss at length
in the days ahead
but for now i just want to congratulate
each of our new colleagues
i look forward to working alongside them
under the previous order the leadership
time is reserved
and under the previous order the senate
will be in a period of morning business
where senators permitted to speak
therein for up to ten minutes each
mr president senator uh
two minutes to speak please
for two purposes one to congratulate my
friend
patrick leahy for once again
assuming the position of president pro
tam
after six years of absence i believe
and also to express my working
relationship with him
in the 40 years that he and i have
served together in the united states
senate
but also to the fourth of state because
we always read about rancor on
television
radio and print they never speak about
how senators get along
we've seen a peaceful transfer of
leadership
position in the united states senate
from a senator from kentucky
to a senator in new york
now for the second purpose of rising
because most of my colleagues don't know
when there's nobody on the senate and i
open the senate up
for uh prayer and uh for the pledge of
allegiance i usually give a one-minute
speech
and i'd like to give my last one minute
speech
as president pro tem not saying i won't
take advantage of that opportunity
when nobody else is around as well
four years ago our nation's capital was
full of people who had come to celebrate
a new president's inauguration and it
was full of people who came to protest
the winner of that election this biden
inauguration was different in that
respect
but this year just like four years ago
there are americans who questioned the
election outcome
and did not want the inauguration to
proceed
since election day i have urged
americans to have faith
in our constitutional system and let the
constitution work the way it has for 240
years
work its course today
was a culmination of that process like
four years ago
i know that many americans are not happy
with how it turned out
that is absolutely fine just like four
years ago was fine for those people
that resisted in our country
nobody is obliged to like or support a
president
but hopefully hopefully people will
really
respect the office of the presidency
regardless who holds it
however while the president's chains
hands
i hope we can retire hashtag
resist you wouldn't know it listening to
partisan commentators from the right
or left but you do not have to make a
choice
between giving your president
unqualified support
or total opposition to the president
as a legislator i want to
i would be doing a disservice to those i
represent
if i did either unqualified support for
a
republican president or total opposition
to a democrat president in my work
on behalf of iowans i have to engage
with the administration of the day
if i want to be a responsible senator
as i have with every president i will
seek to find common ground with
president bryden
biden wherever possible but i will
strongly oppose policies that i think
are not good for iowa
and all americans that will be
on input that i receive from my fellow
iowans
i yield
the majority leader i know the absence
of the cause clerk will call the roll
this baldwin
without objection mr president
senate will be in order the senate will
be in order
mr president earlier today i was proud
to join my colleagues in witnessing the
inauguration of president joe biden
and vice president kamala harris on the
west front of the united states capital
i remembered as i walked away from that
inauguration ceremony the experience i
had four years ago
there was a luncheon traditionally there
is a luncheon given for the new
president and vice president
and that luncheon was my first
opportunity to meet president donald
trump
i'd never met him before and i went up
to him at the head table
and i introduced myself and said i just
want to tell you
that i'm working in the united states
senate for the dream act
i believe that these dreamers deserve a
chance to become part of america's
future
president donald trump minutes after
having taken the oath of office said
senator don't worry about those young
people we'll take care of him
that was my first conversation with
president trump
what transpired afterwards is a matter
of
record in the history of this country
we know also what happened in this
capitol building just two weeks ago
that's why this inauguration was so
different
we were battling a deadly virus and
possibly a deadly attack by american
terrorists
the united states capital was as closely
guarded as i have ever seen it
we estimate that 25 000 soldiers
national guard and active duty soldiers
were in town to protect us
from all around the united states
including 260 from the
state of illinois i'm very proud to
announce
they did their job and did it well i
thank them for
their service and sacrifice and
separation from their families
but at the same time we were facing a
deadly virus
the midst in the midst of a global
pandemic
today's celebration had to be tempered
so that people were safe
where they sat and where they gathered
president biden and vice president
harris understand that our nation
faces a unique set of circumstances they
also understand
that we are a unique nation what makes
it special is that people from all over
the world come to our shores to become
americans
not because of their race or ethnicity
but because they
embrace america's values never before
in american history have those ideals
been tested
as they have been in the last four years
a hallmark of the former administration
was a relentless attack on immigrants
one of the main targets were the very
dreamers that i
spoke to president trump about young
immigrants
came to the united states as children
mr president i asked then said it be
called the senate is not in order please
take your conversations elsewhere
mr president it was 11 years ago that i
joined with then senator dick lugar of
indiana
on a bipartisan basis to call on
president obama to use his legal
authority
to protect dreamers from deportation
our argument was simple these young
people were brought to the united states
as children their parents made the
decision to come here
they grew up here went to school here
pledged allegiance to that very flag
every day in their classrooms and
believed they were part of this country
usually sometime in their teenage years
their parents sat down with them and
told them the grim reality
they have no country not the one they
left nor the one that they currently
live in
and so i introduced legislation 20 years
ago the dream act in an effort
to give them a chance a chance to earn
their way to legal status
and citizenship but i've been unable to
enact that into law
in both the house and the senate in any
given year
i've been stymied and stopped by the
filibuster
too many times but president obama knew
that
when he was a senator here before being
elected the president he was a
co-sponsor of my dream act
so i knew where his heart was and i
appealed to him could he do something
and he did he created daca daca by
executive order provided temporary
protection from deportation of dreamers
if they register with the government pay
a fee pass a criminal national security
background check
they could have a temporary right to
work here in the united states and
be free from deportation more than 800
000 dreamers came forward
with president obama's daca daca
unleashed the full potential of these
dreamers
who are contributing to our country this
very day as soldiers
teachers business owners in the midst of
the covet 19 pandemic
more than 200 000 daca recipients
have been characterized as essential
infrastructure workers
during this pandemic that wasn't my
designation it was the designation of
the trump administration
among those essential workers are 41 700
daca recipients
in the health care industry doctors
intensive care nurses paramedics
and respiratory therapists well on
september 5th of 2017 former president
trump
repealed daca hundreds of thousands of
dreamers faced losing their work permits
and being deported to countries
they barely remembered if remembered at
all last summer the supreme court
rejected
president trump's effort to end
deportation protection for dreamers
in an opinion by chief justice john
roberts
the court held that the president's
attempt to rescind daca
was quote arbitrary and capricious
today in one of his first official acts
president joseph biden signed an
executive order to restore daca
i am eternally grateful for president
biden
courage and commitment and keeping his
word
without daca hundreds of thousands of
talented young people who've grown up in
our country
cannot continue their work and risk
deportation every single day
but the resumption of daca is just the
first step
toward long overdue justice for dreamers
only legislation
passed by congress can provide a path to
citizenship to the dreamers
i first introduced the bipartisan dream
act 20 years ago as i mentioned
and i'll continue to do so until it
becomes the law of the land
i am honored that i have the chance to
serve
as chairman of the senate judiciary
committee in the 117th congress
as a child of an immigrant myself i
never dreamed that i'd be blessed with
the opportunity
to lead the committee that writes our
nation's immigration laws
to all of the dreamers out there i've
told you many times
i've never given up on you don't give up
on me
i'm gonna pass the dreamhack over the
years i've come to the floor
with the most persuasive approach i can
think of
to pass the dream act and make it the
law of the land
i tell their stories these stories show
what's at stake when we consider daca in
the dream act
it is not a theory it is not just a law
these are real human lives to tell today
i want to tell you about hina navid
she's the 127th dreamer whose story i've
told on the floor of the senate
hina was born in pakistan came to the
united states from dubai when she was 10
years old
grew up in fall river massachusetts she
sent me a letter and here's what she
said about growing up
i had a pretty typical experience
navigating a new country in a new school
system
it wasn't until i turned 16 and my peers
were getting their permits to drive
and their first jobs that i really felt
the impact of being undocumented
hino was an excellent student high
school she was president of the national
honor society and key club
she graduated a salutatorian of her
class ranked second out of 350 students
with a 4.0 gpa she received the
outstanding vocational student for
health careers award and overall
outstanding vocational student award she
went to the city university of new york
college of staten island associates
degree in liberal arts and nursing
bachelor of science in nursing
studied at cuny law school where she
graduated with a law degree
and thanks to daca hina became a
registered nurse
she worked as director of health
services for a non-profit community
based organization in new york
her department provides health care
services for children in foster care
many of whom are victims of medical
neglect she's also a member of the new
york city medical reserve corps at the
height of the pandemic
she volunteered on weekends at a
hospital and at a residential facility
with coven 19 patients
hina wrote to me about her plans i want
to work on health policy reform in a
local and state level in an effort to
achieve health quality for all
this pandemic has highlighted health
disparities that long existed
i want to be part of making change i
want to see it and experience it
here's what hina said about daca and
what it meant to her
daca has been life-changing it has
allowed me to drive a car
work achieve fiscal independence
continue
higher education contribute to my
community more than i could otherwise
however it is temporary and with the
benefits it provides it casts a shadow
over my life
i have to plan my life in two-year
increments
well let me start by saying thank you to
her tahina navid for her service on the
front front lines of the coronavirus
pandemic
all of us are in awe of our health care
heroes
she is an immigrant health care hero she
is a daca healthcare hero she has put
herself and her family at risk to
protect
others she also shouldn't have to worry
about being deported tomorrow
and her family facing division
will america be a stronger country if we
just upped and
deported her or if she became an
american citizen
i think the choice is clear hina and
hundreds of thousands of other dreamers
are counting on those of us who serve in
the senate
so here's where we stand the senate
judiciary committee
will soon organize i hope very soon i'll
have an opportunity to appeal to my
colleagues on both sides of the table
join me in a bipartisan effort to pass
the dream act
president biden has made it his clear
priority and i share it
i want this to be the first measure that
we consider
in the area of immigration but i know we
live in a 50-50 senate and it's possible
that once again i'll need to muster 60
votes
to pass this on the floor so whatever we
do it has to be bipartisan
that means it won't have everything in
it that i want or everything that maybe
hina or the advocates want but we have
to take a step forward
once and for all to help these young
people
as long as i am a senator i will
continue to fight for hina navid
and for people who have come to this
country just to make it better it would
be an american tragedy to deport
this brave and talented health care
professional in the midst of a pandemic
we must assure that she and hundreds of
thousands in
our essential workforce are not forced
to stop contributing when the need for
their service has never been greater
and we must give them the chance they
deserve to become american citizens
i cannot express my gratitude enough for
president biden
on the first hours that he was in office
to recognize
the needs of the daca recipients and the
dreamers
i want to work with him and work with
both parties across the aisle
to make this dream come true for so many
who deserve it
they've waited long enough mr president
i yield the floor
mr president senator from arkansas for
the information of other senators who
want to know if we'd have a vote tonight
specifically on the nomination of avril
haynes to be director of national
intelligence
uh i was the last person to object
holding that vote i no longer object i
wanted to have
a question for the record answered miss
haines
thankfully has responded my question
yesterday i want to thank
senator rubio and senator warner for
helping us get that answer specifically
in her open session yesterday
she gave an answer in response to
senator wyden that suggested the
intelligence community might reopen
investigations into detention
interrogation programs
from 2001 2006. she clarified in the
private setting that we had
that she had no intention to open up
those investigations and expose
operations officers inside the cia
to criminal prosecution or adverse
employment action
or even uh holding it against them in
potential
future promotions or placements she's
confirmed that in the written record
i'm glad to see that we're not going to
reopen that period i want to thank miss
haines for providing the answer
most importantly i want to thank our
brave operation and para military
operations officers and the cia for what
they do
always to keep this country safe so i'm
ready to vote on this nomination i
believe the rest of senate is as well
i yield back the floor
and i note the absence of a quorum clerk
will call the roll
mr ms baldwin
the senator from florida mr president i
asked the unanimous consent that the
quorum call be initiated without
objection
at uh at noon today joe biden was
sworn in as our new president i never
served
with president biden when he was a
senator but
i can tell you that from direct and
first-hand experience
that he is a man of tremendous empathy
i've witnessed it
um and so i pray that god will bless him
with strength
with health with wisdom because i don't
need
to tell anyone that we in our nation are
living in troubled times
you know president trump was elected and
then in his last cycle received 75
million votes
in part because he spoke to and was
brutally honest about
some of the grievances and the fears
that are now dividing our country
it's important to understand he didn't
create them
and it's that's why his exit alone
is not going to make america normal
again
the troubles we face the things that now
divide us uh
really aren't so much about politics or
about ideology if you look into them
they're really
more about the things that are at the
core of our identity as a nation and as
a people
people want a country where you can
everybody has the opportunity to find a
good job
to get married to live in a safe
neighborhood
to not go into debt because you have a
baby
to send their kids to a good school and
one day to retire with dignity and
security
but we have millions of americans who
increasingly feel that that kind of life
and those kinds of things are
out of reach for them and they're really
frustrated that
neither those in government or either
political party seems to be doing much
about it
their people need a sense of belonging
and and purpose
but the places that we used to get that
from our families
the community groups we join the
synagogue the churches
many of them are in collapse and so now
you have millions of people that feel
isolated or
alienated and some who are turning to
hybrid
hyper-partisan politics and even online
conspiracy cults to fill
the void that those institutions once
filled
the overwhelming majority of americans
reject
racism and bigotry and discrimination
but they also reject identity politics
which
constantly seems to want to divide us
against in
and apart from each other on the basis
of race and ethnicity and
gender we are a nation that is proud of
our heritage as a nation of immigrants
but millions of americans i would say
the majority also believe we're a nation
that has to have immigration laws
they need to be followed and they need
to be enforced
most americans accept that our country
our society is changing
and they understand that there are
people with different views and
different ways of life what they do
resent
is efforts to demonize and to persecute
those who hold the traditional values
that are
inherited from our judeo-christian
heritage
most americans believe decency and
morality requires everyone is entitled
to dignity and to respect
but there are also many growing
increasingly tired of walking on the
eggshells of political correctness and
forced to undergo sensitivity training
because everyone
seems to be so easily offended these
days by everything
people understand we've got to do
something it's a problem we've got to do
something about people who use social
media
to spread dangerous lies to instigate
violence
but i think they also have a right to be
very troubled that five
ceo tech a ceo of technology companies
five people
in five companies elected by no one
accountable to no one
have the power if they so choose
to wipe out to silence anyone
even a president
and i would tell you almost without
exception they were horrified
horrified about what happened here two
weeks ago today
they want those people in jail
but they also wonder where was that
outrage
when this summer in multiple cities
across a number of
months there were people setting fire to
police cars and breaking into
police stations and attacking
courthouses and looting private property
and i'll tell you they see first hand
every day
the extraordinary damage being done by
this terrible pandemic
and the damage being done by our bitter
divisions
which is i frankly i think most
americans will never understand why the
first thing we're going to do here
potentially is an impeachment trial of a
president that isn't even in office
anymore
what happened today was incredibly
important the pageantry the rituals
behind it
it matters you know for the 59th time in
our history we
peacefully transferred power from one
leader to the next
and i think the fact that that happened
on the very steps of this capital
where just two weeks ago on this day
we saw an unimaginable attack on
democracy
that should serve as a reminder to all
of us in this country
and a powerful message to the world
that our republic remains resilient
but now the hard work of self-government
begins
and these anxieties i've just described
of tens of millions of americans
they need to be acknowledged and they
need to be addressed
if they are ignored if they are allowed
to fester
what it will do is it will leave us not
just a nation that is paralyzed
and can't take action on important
issues
we're going to be left a nation that
remains vulnerable
to those who are willing to exploit and
stir
the most destructive impulses
today president biden struck important
tones of national unity and i believe
that they were sincere
but pursuing a radical agenda
in a country so divided is does not
serve the cause of unity it will only
serve
cynicism that destroys trust
by the same token continuing to fan the
flames of grievances
or in the alternative pursuant vengeance
disguised as accountability will not
serve the cause of unity either
that is nothing but the politics of
resentment and retribution
which only leads to a fractured nation
of people who literally come to hate
each other
demanding that the other side in a
debate on a topic on a principle
that that they agree with you on
everything that that isn't unity
that's that's the arrogance of believing
that any of us
we are the sole holders of the truth
anyone who agrees with us is good and
anyone who disagrees with us is wrong
not just wrong but actually evil
the truth is real unity isn't everyone
having the same ideology or the same
views or the same ideas the unity we
need actually comes from
remembering remembering who we actually
are
we americans are not a racist or
nativist people
we are good and compassionate people who
in its overwhelming majority they do not
ask
about race when they donate unwrapped
toys so that no child
has to wake up on christmas morning with
no present under the tree
they don't ask where a soldier or a
sailor or an airman and woman's
parents came from when they put together
and send care packages to them
halfway around the world as they defend
us
we americans are bold people in our
veins
liberty runs the blood of pilgrims
of settlers of exiles of immigrants
of people who overcame slavery and then
segregation
who refused the people who are we are
the descendants of people who refused
to surrender to fear and to abandon
their hope of a better life
we americans are not the inheritors of
an american dream that some prize
that we have to fight against one
another for in some winner take all
competition
we are the inheritors of an american
dream which
anyone can achieve without it being
denied
someone else this
is who we were when this country
inspired and changed the world
and i hope that this is who we will be
again
a people who disagree over principle who
argue over policies
that has to happen because our republic
depends on every view of having a voice
and every voice having a place to be
heard
but also people who now
understand that the choice before us is
we will either find a way to share a
nation and a future
or we will all share the condemnation of
history
and the rebuke of americans yet to come
mr president i yield the floor
president the senior senator from oregon
mr president i rise to discuss
the nomination of avril haynes to be
director
of national intelligence i think my
colleagues know
that in a few minutes the senate will be
voting on her nomination for this
key position i briefly
intend to outline where i think
things stand on several sensitive issues
with the 17 agencies that make up
the intelligence community the biden
administration and miss haines
have an opportunity and a duty
to turn the page on the cover-ups
and lawlessness of the outgoing
administration
that is why i asked ms haines
at her confirmation hearing
whether she would abide by a law
that i authored requiring an
unclassified report on who
was responsible for the killing of
washington post
journalist jamal khashoggi
jamal khashoggi was a u.s resident
who was lured to the saudi consulate
in istanbul and brutally
murdered despite press stories
stating that the saudi arabian leader
was responsible for the killing
the trump administration stayed mum
just stoned one for a whole year
the trump administration just ignored
the law that i wrote
so i asked ms haines at our hearing
whether she would follow the law
and provide that unclassified report
on who was responsible for jamal
khashoggi's murder
ms haines response was straightforward
she said she would provide the report
and comply with the law that statement
as frankly modest as it was
was a sea change colleagues
from the obstructionism and
stonewalling of the trump administration
the trump administration had basically
taken the position
on laws like this transparency measure
that
it was kind of optional for the
executive branch to comply
so ms haines direct commitment
to making that key report
on the role of mbs saudi leader
in the murder of jamal khashoggi in my
view
was a real step forward for the rule of
law
for accountability for human rights
and i'll say as a journalist kid
it was a real step forward for freedom
of the press everywhere
the second subject i discussed with ms
haynes
was a particularly troubling aspect
of the cia's recent history
the cia spied on the staff of the senate
intelligence committee
when the staff was writing the torture
report
as deputy director ms haines didn't hold
anyone accountable in my view
this abuse this spying
on the senate select committee on
intelligence
basically colleagues turns the whole
concept of overhead
on its head the united states congress
is supposed to do oversight on the
executive branch
and not vice versa
in response to my questions at the
hearing
ms haines admitted that the spying on
the committee
was wrong she also agreed
that she supported recommendations to
expand accountability and would apply
that expanded accountability
to the intelligence community at large
and when she was asked about the cia's
baseless efforts to have committee staff
prosecuted
she agreed there ought to be guard rails
against that happening
again the third area
i explored with the nominee was the need
to rebuild
trust in the intelligence community
which in
my view requires a new focus
on transparency and openness
for example there ought to be
transparency so that the american
people know what kind of surveillance
is being conducted on them the president
of the senate knows about the important
vote
we had on that amendment that i offered
the bipartisan
senator danes because we ought to
get history on whether the government
is spying on the browsing history of the
american people so
this is really
a critical and growing concern
because we're all seeing about data
brokers and others
selling people's data and it's
especially important that the american
people are told
if the government is using legal
loopholes
in the law and the warrant requirement
of the fourth fourth amendment so i
asked
ms haines about circumstances in which
the government
instead of getting an order just goes
out and purchases the private records of
americans
from these sleazy and unregulated
commercial data brokers who are simply
above the law literally
above the law i believe this practice is
unacceptable
and soon i will be introducing
legislation
to make it clear that the fourth
amendment
is not for sale
now for congress to tackle the topic
it's vitally important there'd be an
informed public debate
and what the government is collecting
right now and what it believes is a
legal basis for the collection
and i was encouraged by how ms haines
responded
to that question i asked she said it was
critical that the american people have
an understanding
of when and under what authorities the
government is buying their private data
now miss haines made a number of
other commitments related to
transparency issues
many of which relate to a problem
i have come to describe as secret
law and to my colleagues we see our
new members here you know people think
when a law is written
they go to a coffee shop in atlanta or
athens
or tucson and they read
about a law and they think it's what the
public law says
but secret law is based on the
proposition that
after the public law is put in place the
government
often reinterprets the public law in
secret keeps the new interpretation
secret
under the pretext that these
reinterpretations are just so
key to keeping americans safe
the reality is that the interpretations
of public law ought to be transparent
and public as well and it comes down to
a very straightforward principle
i'm a strong opponent of secret law i'm
a strong support
supporter of transparency and i
intend to remind director haines
what she told me just a few days ago
about
transparency and to push hard for the
public release
of as much information as possible
when americans deserve to see it
and they can see it when it's consistent
with their safety and well-being of
their households
and their loved ones i also intend to
push
the director of national intelligence to
fix a broken declassification system
for years a flood of new digitally
classified information
has overwhelmed an obsolete paper-based
declassification system
this system is so out of whack
that in order to get a document
declassified
government officials actually have to
walk the
document around washington from
agency to agency i actually said at our
open hearing i wonder
if it's getting to the point where to
get a document declassified
someone who works for the government has
got to pack a lunch
put the document in their big black
briefcase and then
make their way all over the nation's
capital
so i've introduced with senator moran
bipartisan legislation
to authorize the director of national
intelligence to fix the problem
ms haines has acknowledged the
seriousness of the problem
and the dni's role in fixing it it's my
intent to make sure
that this also is not
allowed to just continue as business
as usual some of the starkest
differences between the eight actions of
the outgoing administration
and the positions taken by ms haynes
here
a couple of days ago relate to the
crucial
area of whistleblowers the outgoing
administration
broke the law when it was held from
congress the complaint of the ukraine
whistleblower
the whistleblower who had identified
abuses that resulted in the first
impeachment of donald trump
this lawlessness undermined
both the whistleblower system and the
independence of the intelligence
community inspector general
who determined that the complaint ought
to be submitted to congress ms haynes
has been clear
the law requires that when the inspector
general
determines that a whistleblower
complaint is urgent
the director of national intelligence
cannot keep it from the congress
she made other commitments to
whistleblowers
there are whistleblower protection laws
including some that have been approved
by the senate intelligence committee
that need to be enacted there are
procedures already required by law
that the outgoing administration just
didn't
issue they just stonewalled after all
the
damage done by the trump administration
with respect to
trampling on the public's right to know
and transparency where the information
can be
made public to the american people
without compromising sources and methods
i'll tell you the biden administration
has a lot of work to do to repair and
improve whistleblower protections
they're going to have a lot on their
plate the country has massive cyber
vulnerabilities
that we saw just a couple of weeks ago
there's more to do in terms of
preventing foreign interference in our
elections
we have to ensure that other
surveillance programs provide
security without sacrificing sacrificing
our constitutional rights i'm going to
close by way of saying
i don't assume that i'll always agree
with the incoming administration
that's been true for me with democrats
and republicans on these issues
when we disagree we'll have a vigorous
debate as vigorous
as when i disagreed with the trump
administration ms haines
is dni ambassador burns as cia
director are beginning to shape
up as a team that will be more open with
the public
respect the law work with the congress
to repair the vast damage
of the outgoing administration and
respect
you know what ben frankly ben franklin
talked about
so many years ago liberty and security
aren't mutually exclusive
smart policies get you both not so smart
policies get you less
of both and that's our challenge
so tonight because of her answers to me
at the open intelligence committee
hearing
a couple of days ago as president i want
to say
in closing i'm going to be supporting ms
haynes nomination to be the director of
national intelligence
the senator from virginia mr president i
ask unanimous consent that the senate
proceed to executive session
and the intelligence committee be
discharged from
further consideration of pn 7810
the nomination of avril haynes to be
director of national intelligence
that the senate proceed its
consideration that to be ten minutes for
debate on the nomination
equally divided in the usual form that
upon the use or yielding back of time
the senate vote
without intervening action or debate
that have confirmed the motion be
to reconsider be considered made and
laid upon the table and the president
immediately notified the senate's action
is there objection without objection so
ordered
the clerk will report
nomination director of national
intelligence
avril danika haynes of new york to be
director
mr president i rise in strong support of
the nomination of avril haynes
to be director of national intelligence
and i'm going to
speak for a few moments but i want to
first of all
thank members of in particular the
intelligence committee on both sides of
the aisle
my good friend the center from morgan
the
finance committee chairs is uh someone
who has deep and passionate
concerns about the civil libertarian
issues
in our country um he was part of the
ying when
there's some yang on that committee uh
he raised i think important questions
and important questions
uh with the nominee and um appreciate
his
his courtesy and allowing this to move
forward but i also want to thank
um at least until tomorrow the chairman
of the committee senator rubio
and my republican colleagues as well um
when we discussed moving on this
nomination
in a very timely manner uh particular
chairman rubio
and senator burr work with all the
members of the committee
i want to thank my friend the center
from idaho
um for his courtesy as well
and very proud of the fact that
the first nomination to be considered
under the biden administration is going
to be ms haynes
and i think that reflects the
approach of the intelligence committee
and again i see the
the chair of the committee on the floor
now i again want to thank him
personally senator rubio uh while he's
on the floor for
that courtesy now i think part of the
reason why we were able to move so
quickly is the
this position is such is of such
critical importance to the country
that it is only appropriate that it be
the first nomination
to be confirmed by the senate and avril
is an extraordinarily qualified for the
role having worked in national security
for most of the last two decades
after working for several years at the
state department ms haynes came here to
the state
senate where she worked in the foreign
relations committee
as the deputy chief counselor following
another stint at state
ms haynes moved to the white house where
she served three years
as a deputy assistant the president and
the deputy council for national security
in june of 2013 president obama chose ms
haynes
to serve as the deputy director of the
cia
making her the first woman to hold that
office
ms haynes served at the agency until
2015 at which point she moved to
academia and the private sector
she was a senior researcher at columbia
university
a senior fellow at johns hopkins applied
physics lab
and a member of the national commission
on military
national and public service avril haynes
has all the qualifications we would want
for a dni
but more than that i believe she is
firmly committed
to rebuilding the office of the director
of national intelligence
and re-establishing the role of that
office
as not only the coordinator of our
nation's intelligence community
but as an advisor to the president and
congress
that will not shy away from telling the
hard truths
since ms haynes was nominated for this
role by president biden
i spent a fair amount of time talking to
her
about her future as the director of
national intelligence and the enormous
job
that she'll be taking on in our
conversations
and in her confirmation hearings miss
haines was a strong
was strong and thoughtful about the
future challenges our country will face
my first question to her was about china
her answer was equally clear-eyed
pointing out the many ways in which
china is an adversary to our nation by
stealing i.p
or hacking our systems and undermining
our security
while also pointing out that there are
many places where we'll have to engage
with china
as a partner like on tackling climate
change
she had equally focused answers about
the role of iran as a state sponsor of
terror
and the need to prevent iran from
acquiring a nuclear weapon
for every question she was asked by my
colleagues on the committee
she demonstrated that she understood not
the challenges
of the coming future not only the
challenge of the coming future but the
ic's roles
in understanding those issues and
meeting them head on
i've also been impressed from the
beginning and continue to be impressed
by our understanding of the important
role of the dni
and the ic and our commitment to making
sure
that the ic tells policymakers what they
need to hear
not only what they want to hear the last
four years
have been hard on the intelligence
community
you only have to read a newspaper or
turn on a tv at some point to know that
since the 2016 election the ic has faced
false accusations of trying to undermine
the then president
and seeing many of their leaders fired
for simply doing the right thing
speaking truth to power it should
surprise no one
that all of this has led to some damage
within the ic
particularly to morale i believe
that if real haines is the right nominee
to repair this damage
she will support the men and women of
the ic and protect them
from political pressure she will insist
that they tell us
their best analysis and not shy away
from telling decision makers
that their cherished beliefs are wrong
she will insist
on telling truth to power ultimately
this is why i urge my colleagues to send
a strong message of support
for the men and women of the ic into
support of real haines for dni
she is capable qualified and will
undertake its serious responsibilities
with a clear-eyed sense of promise thank
you
with that i yield the floor
and note the absence of quality
degrading of the presidency
to yield back all time objection
the question occurs on the nomination
ask the yeas and nays
is there a sufficient second there
appears to be the clerk will call the
roll
it's baldwin
mr barrasso
mr bennett
this is blackburn
you
mr blunt mr booker
mr boseman
mr brawn
is
mr booker mr bozeman mr braun mr brown
miss cantwell mrs capito
mr cardin mr carper mr casey mr cassidy
ms collins mr coons
mr cornyn miss cortes masto
mr cotton mr kramer mr crapo mr cruz
mr daines miss duckworth
mr durbin
miss ernst have a good night
mrs feinstein mrs fisher
this is jill brown
mr graham mr grassley
mr hagerty
miss hassan mr hawley mr heinrich
mr hickenlooper miss hirono
mr hoeven mrs hyde smith
mr inhofe mr johnson
mr johnson
mr kane mr kelly mr kennedy mr king
ms klobuchar mr langford
mr leahy mr lee
mr lujan miss lomas
mr manchin mr markey mr marshall
mr mcconnell mr menendez
mr merkley mr moran
mrs murkowski
mr murphy this is murray
mr ossoff
mr padilla
mr paul
mr peters mr portman
mr reed mr risch
mr romney
ms rosen mr rounds mr rubio
mr sanders mr stass
mr schatz
mr schumer
mr scott of florida
mr scott of south carolina
mr shelby
miss cinema miss smith
miss stavenow
mr sullivan
mr tester mr thune
mr tillis
yes
mr chubberville
mr van hollen
mr warner mr warnock
miss warren
mr whitehouse mr wicker mr wyden
mr young
do
senators voting in the affirmative
baldwin barrasso booker bozeman
burr capitol cardin
carper casey cassidy
cornyn cortez masto cotton
duckworth durbin feinstein fisher
graham grassley hasson hyde smith
kane kelly kennedy klobuchar
lummus markey menendez moran
murkowski murray padilla
reed romney rosen rounds
rubio sas scott of florida
cinema smith sullivan tester
tuberville warner warnock
warren wicker
mr lankford i
mr shelby i
senators voting in the negative ernst
lee marshall paul
mr inhofe mr inhofe i
miss cantwell miss can't well i
mr king mr king i
mr schatz mr schatz
i mr schumer mr schumer
aye
mr johnson mr johnson i
miss hirono miss hirono i
mr leahy mr leahy aye
mr young mr young i
mr mcconnell mr mcconnell
i mr coons mr coons
aye mrs blackburn mrs blackburn
no
mr murphy mr murphy aye
mr blumenthal mr blumenthal
i
mr lujan mr lujan i
mr portman mr portman i
mr wyden mr wyden i
mr ossoff mr ossoff
i
you
mr sanders mr sanders
i mr bennett mr bennett
i
mr hickenloop mr higgin luber
i miss collins miss collins
i
you
mr risch mr rish no
mr danes mr danes i
do
you
mr merkley mr markley i
mr mansion mr mansion i
you
mr heinrich mr heinrich
aye
mr thune mr thune aye
mr kramer mr kramer i
mr agardy mr hagerty no
mr peters mr peters
aye
so
foreign
mr hoeven mr hovind i
you
so
you
mrs gillibrand i
mrs shakeem mrs shaheen
i
so
mr hawley mr hawley now
you
you